all right guys everyone can hear me well
uh so yes I'm Peter hollanda I'm one of
the main contributors of duct TV and I'm
here today to tell you guys a little bit
about it I know another person talking
about a new database system but I hope
I'll convince you guys that there was
the need to build a new database system
uh and I'm going to be talking about how
it actually interacts with the whole
python ecosystem
um so that's the outline of our talk
I'm going to start a little bit with
what is duct TB so just give you like a
very brief motivation and what are the
actual main characteristics so the main
design decisions that we did there uh
then gonna talk a little bit about the
deck to be the python land and do a very
quick demo seven to ten minutes uh this
demo is about uh estimating the New York
City tax defer costs with that being
pandas so it's not really replacing
pandas for those who saw the talk
earlier a lot of people trying to
replace uh replace pandas we're not here
to try to defron the king but to work
together to make it better
uh and at the end like a short summary
of The Talk
all right so what is ductibly uh so deck
DB was actually born at CWI which is the
research center of mathematics and
informatics uh uh for Amsterdam and in
there we're oh yeah I mean there we're
basically working and we're all like PT
students or researchers and we're all uh
working with uh data science projects
that were from actual companies and we
quickly realized that in all these
projects no one's actually using
database systems they were all writing
their own code through parse their CSV
files or parquet files and it starts to
use pandas to do uh database operations
and start to question ourselves as
database researchers okay why is that
the case so well if you actually want to
use a database system into in a python
application or an analytical tool you
can do it by database connection so you
have like your rdbms probably if you do
analytics you're doing something like
click house and then for your database
connection you pass on the data to your
python application and you'll do I don't
know machine learning data science or
whatnot the problem here is that this
becomes quite expensive because you have
this transfer cost
so we felt like well what if we can
actually bet a database system inside
the analytical store like sqlite does of
course sqlite is a database system
that's catered For transaction workloads
so usually you request from Topo you
update something on that turbo not
really for analytics where you're
getting like huge chunks of the data and
Performing some kind of aggregation or
machine learning operation top of it so
what if we can be the sqlites for
Analytics
and that's how the view was born so as
you can see duct TV the sqlite for
analytics some of you probably heard
this a couple times today already uh and
it's like okay we want to be like
sqlites in the sense of it's simple to
install like we want people to be
pleased to use it not have to start a
whole server to create a table schema to
then load their CSV files or transform
their pocket files there we want simple
stuff so it needs to be simple to be
installed just people style duct deep in
Python for example and you're ready to
go embedded so you have no server
management uh fast analytical processing
so really focus and cater it for
analytical workloads and you need to
have fast transfer between our Python
and the database management system
um drb is current they actually
pre-release as the version 0.6 and we
say it's pre-release because our storage
is still
um not consistent between versions so in
following versions uh this you basically
have to reload all your data you can
check the website for more details
all right so what are the
characteristics I'm actually going to be
talking about today this is a little bit
technical but I promise I'll try to make
it fun uh or at least like engaging
um so I'm going to talk a bit about
color data storage
data compression vectorized execution
end-to-end query optimization automatic
parallelism and Beyond memory execution
so common data storage
um
as you might know there are basically
two ways of storing your data you can do
it I can do it either as a Road store or
a column store as a road star example
you have sqlites and the thing about the
road store is that your data is
continuously in memory uh per row right
so you have the first row second row
third row so and so forth it means that
individual rows can be fetched very
cheaply because it's just a sequential
part of your memory however if you're
fetching uh only one column of your
whole table that also means that you're
probably going to read your whole table
so in this example here we have a couple
columns dates store product customer
price uh and what if we only
want to run a query very interested in
the price of a product and all the
stores in which it sold doesn't really
matter if we go for the whole column
we're going to fetch the whole table
and that's what column storage is for uh
now you you actually store the column
continuously in memory so you can fetch
the columns individually and this can
cause immense service on disk IO and a
memory bandwidth when you have this
typical analytical queries where you
only get a few Columns of your whole
table and as an example of thumb stores
you have pandas inductibly
so to give you an example of what kind
of savings we can have here let's say we
have a one terabyte table with 100
columns and we just want to get five
columns of the table but the the four
columns so in a row store if you really
there's one terabyte where if your disk
going at 100 megabytes per second that
takes three hours but in the column
store you suddenly don't have to read
your whole table anymore you can just
fetch the columns you need so to read
these five columns is about 50 gigs this
goes to eight minutes so these are the
main design difference that I want to
show here from like something like
sqlites or
transactional database to analytical uh
database data management tools
the other thing we have in that DB is
compression so you can notice that
individual columns they often have very
similar values for example if you have a
Time series database you usually have
dates they are stored like increasingly
so instead of storing the actual dates
you can store their difference and save
space there or if you have a lot of
repeated values you can apply your rle
which is basically saying if you have
six tuples where the value is R6 instead
of storing six six six six six six
historically six times six so it's just
like simple compression techniques but I
can bring your data size to a very low
value and here I have an example of a
couple some some of the dict DB versions
so about a year and a half ago at
version 0.2.8 we had no compression
and today we implemented a bunch of
different things there rle bitpacking
dictionary double compression like a
fsst and chimp and for very common
benchmarks so for example the table from
tpca is lining item or the famous taxi
data sets we managed to get already in a
year and a half three to five times
compression so you can get a lot from
this
and how does compression actually change
in your execution well again if we go to
the same example where we have five
columns on the table and you want to
read these five columns with no
compression you have to go 50 gigabytes
so that will take you eight minutes but
compressing them with 5x you can get to
like 10 gigabytes which already reduce
your time even further a minute and 40.
um in this compression uh can also go to
the execution but currently inductive is
only really in our storage
um what about execution well sqlites
uses step water time processing which
means that when you have your query plan
you have one top or going through each
operator up to your results uh pandas
uses what we call call Meta time
processing which basically means you
process the whole column on each
operator of your plan inductively uses
vectorized processing which is kind of a
mix you don't really do one top or you
don't really do one column you do a
batch and this batch has a magic number
there which is 2048 elements and that's
what you go passing up to the to the
topper for plan
so okay so top at a time of sqlize uh
it's actually optimized for low memory
footprints uh
uh it comes from a time that a memory is
very expensive and your data probably
didn't fit completely in memory and it's
very nice because you actually only have
to keep one single Row in memory however
for analytics it's quite costly because
it adds a lot of overhead on your CPU so
every Tempo that's going on in your plan
you have a function call get your query
quite expensive
uh pandas during the column at a time it
actually presents a better CPU
utilization it allows for CMD but has
one big issue which is you actually have
to materialize your whole column at each
operator of your query uh so you end up
materializing large intermediates in
memory these intermediates can be
gigabytes each
and this becomes quite problematic when
data size are large I guess a lot of
people are faced this issue where your
data just does not fit in memory but
it's like ah okay I give up
um and then vectorize is what the
activity does I said this is optimized
for CPU cache locality uh Sim allows for
Sim destructions and Pipeline and the
whole idea is that you actually have
your intermediates that's also why you
have this 2048 number is that they
actually can fit on L1 so basically I'm
not sure how familiar guys are with a
modern uh CPUs but basically you have a
CPU car and you have this L1 l2l free
caches and the main memory the bigger
the gets the more expensive it gets to
access data so if your data feeds on
that one cache you're processing the
whole query plan paying only latency of
one and a second but again in the
example of Ponders if you have your
whole data fitting in main memory it
means that every time you go in there
you pay the latency of 400 nanoseconds
and it starts to accumulate and it
presents a huge bottleneck on a query
processing
um end-to-end Square optimization yeah
so inductively as a good database
management system we have an Optimizer
that means your Expressions can be
optimized that means join ordering if
you have multiple joints they are going
to be reordered uh to
start processing from where you have
more uh the least amount of topos we
have sub require flattening so instead
of having sub queries executing where
you have a bunch of function calls every
time that you want to execute sub query
you actually can transform it to a join
and we even have a filtering projection
pushed down which is actually a pretty
uh basic optimization but it's one that
fundus does not do so just to Showcase
what if projection push down would be
here we have a table with just five
columns a b c d e right and then we have
a query there which is just getting the
minimum of a where a is higher than zero
Group by B so that means that to run
this query you won't need two columns A
and B so you can see here in padas that
you actually oh sorry inductibly that
you actually push down these two columns
to this so they scan so that means that
these columns are the only things you're
reading but in pandas unless you set it
up initially and manually that means
that when you go to the filter DF there
where you're just getting all the tuples
are higher than zero you're still
scanning the whole table so
simple query optimizations they come for
free inductively
uh automatic parallelism and Beyond
memory execution uh so duct B has
parallel version of most of its
operators I'd like to say it all but
I'll go with most uh scanners uh so in
the all the all the scanners or data
scanners they are paralyzed and they
have the option of preserving insertion
order uh aggregations joints uh and as
you might have heard uh pandas of course
can only support single Friday execution
uh inductive B also supports execution
of data that does not fit in memory so
our main goal is to never crash we never
give up we Never Surrender we're gonna
execute whatever query and we're the
user might throw at us even if it
doesn't fit in memory we try to have
graceful degradation so there's
certainly not a huge cost uh for uh for
the query that when it not fits and
never crashing
all right that could be in the python
land
um so yeah so drb has mainly two apis uh
it has a python DBI API uh it's partial
DBI API compliance which means that you
can create connections get cursors
executes fetch all fetch many fetch one
everything that's defined there and we
also have a relational API the idea of
the relation API is that you have
something that's somewhat familiar to
pandas is not a one-to-one mapping but
you can say like okay you can get for
example here we have our database and it
has a table called integers so you can
use ducted B dot table to get that
relation and then that relation you can
for example use show to print what's in
there actually prints off a limit so
just that you have a feeling
and you can also chain moods for
operators very similar to father so you
can say like a filter projection and
then do a prints
uh integration so we have a lot of I'll
say very tight Integrations with
different uh python libraries and with
title I mean they are zero copy uh not
always but most of the times uh for
inputs and outputs so for example for
pandas uh in the code example here we
have a data frame two columns we create
a connection that b and then we can
actually select the elements from the
data frame so we can run a query select
star from DF DF is the name of the data
frame and we can actually scan the
values there without copying it and we
can get the results from this query
which should be the data frame values
again but we can export it to a data
frame as well again zero copy so we can
interact with data frames uh without
paying any huge costs in this the same
thing with pi Arrow so we do the same
with arrow a very similar example to the
panels one we can just select from Arrow
objects Arrow tables errors streams and
you can also produce them we have the
same with numpy we also are integrated
of SQL Alchemy and we have integrated
with Ibis to the point that we actually
became I think recently there are
default back-ends
uh a bit of usage so as you can tell
last month we had about 640
000 downloads in our python API daily
about 32 000 downloads so
these numbers have been increasing quite
fast but we uh we are growing growing in
terms of how many downloads we got in
our python package and how much used it
is uh exactly because of these uh
Integrations we have
all right now it's time for a quick demo
let me make this bigger can you guys
from the back seats
I hear it yes okay so yes all right so
this demo as well was going to be pretty
simple uh so here it's just showing like
okay
this pre here is just to get like the
latest version and then you get like
their sets which is a parquet file with
the New York City uh cab data sets for
the January of 2016.
uh report our libraries we're going to
be using pandas some timing library and
techdb
and you can just load the data with
pandas so to loaded in pandas this is a
parquet file we can just use read
parquet and we get our data frame
takes a little bit of a little for
whatever yeah all right here we just
have like a very simple time function
nothing too fancy here just runs five
times gets a mean value uh
and then we're basically going to be
calling this guy for uh all the queries
are going to be running uh during the
demo uh so here
the goal we have here first is like okay
let's let's pretend we have this
question like okay we have all this
information about cab rides uh does the
average tip value actually increase the
more passengers we have for short strips
um so the more people you have in the
car higher the tip or not and then to
answer that question in DirecTV of
course you can just use SQL you can get
the passenger account an average of
cheap amounts you can scan exactly from
the data frame so you just have to pass
the data frame name here set your where
Clause okay where the distance is lower
than five uh and you Group by the
passenger accounts
uh and again the nice thing of this is
that you can also return a data frame
here
and why would it be interesting to
return a data frame well fondas actually
has this very nice integration for
example with plotting so since we got a
result of their frame here we can just
call plot bar and then immediately you
get like a nice figure about it so what
you can see here is that it's probably
some dirty data there because there's
zero passenger accounts or maybe and
somehow they're also getting tips I'm
not sure if that's how it works
um but otherwise Apparently after uh
eight passengers which I guess you
probably get like some kind of minivan
your tip value increases there so there
is
to a certain number some correlation to
how much money you get from your tips
for short distances and again doing the
same thing in pandas
would actually be okay we want to filter
the data frame get all the travels that
had a distance lower than five grouped
by the passenger counts and get the mean
value of the tip and then basically we
do the same here like we do the plots
um and like what I want to showcase here
is actually the difference in timing and
keep in mind that this is small data
sets and this I think the collab machine
has like two cars so the parallelism
here it's also not that big but duck DB
we run the square in 0.26 seconds and
then if we go to pandas is 1.37 so even
for not such a complex query
small data sets not a beefy machine
there's a very like quite a big
difference and that's again not really
exploiting as well uh out of uh core
execution pandas will just crash there
unless of course you do some manual
handling and then I also have an example
like okay you're showing like showing me
something that's not really data sciency
let's do something a bit more fancy can
we do estimate Fair uh with the linear
regression inductive B so how much the
distance of the trip will actually a
fact so I'm not going to go in the
details of the scoring but the score is
basically calculating uh the alpha and
beta for our regression
and I really just want to show you that
this is actually possible to be executed
as well so here we present like our
office 4.65 beta 2.66 and then again you
can just output a data frame for this
and actually plot it very nicely so
there you go we have our linear
regression and again just as
confirmation I can do the same in pandas
uh also this time just calculating the
Alpha and the beta and that's the only
thing that I'm actually timing it here
and we can see that it's going to take a
little longer than it actually be
a little longer yeah all right 2.18 so
the time here you can check the Alpha
and the batter is the same right the
data is the same so 4.66 here is also
for
4.65 4.65 2.66 2.66 the time here is 0.7
seconds and Depends that's 2.1 so yeah
that's a free x difference again
query now is a little bit more complex
but it still is really not stressing out
uh the full potential because of the
machine but you can already see there's
like a noticeable difference there
um all right
all right that's gonna be my last slides
so it's a bit of a summary
um yeah so drb is an embedded database
system
it's designed for analytical course so
it's really catered for data analysis
data science it's completely open source
under MIT license which is the most
permissive license there is and free to
use so if you download it it basically
get the max out of the activity
um has binding for many languages python
R Java uh javascripts like if there's a
language you probably have a binding for
it now I think it is the integrator of
the Python ecosystem so zero copy access
to python then Pi Pi Arrow data sets uh
implements the B the DVI and relational
apis and has full SQL support and that's
something that I really want to stress I
know data scientists love their training
operators but SQL is cool we fully
support it you can just run SQL on data
frames I think that's very nice
um that's it's from my size
um yeah and I'll be very happy to take
any questions if you guys have them
thank you very much for paying attention
[Applause]
thanks for your talk looks very uh
interesting I'm definitely going to
check it out so does it support uh
usually defined functions in in the
execution engine yes it does support
user defined functions uh I mean you can
Implement them in C plus plus but uh
they are not in Python for example
so yeah as long as there's the same
language as the core you can Implement
them there yeah but I mean uh for in
panels you can simply write a python
function that does some kind of
manipulation of a column that might not
be easily expressible in SQL so can you
I mean I mean that that's also what's
very powerful about it right uh since
you can actually get your data for
example as a data frame
you can also exploit things or
operations that might exist on data
frames already that might not exist
inductively so it's also easy to
integrate with them and again that's
also like the thing while it's
Integrations like using the best that
pandas has to offer which is years and
years and years of development but it's
still like keeping the fast score
execution where unnecessary yeah cool
thanks
anyone else maybe all the way in the
back to give me some extra steps there
we go
oh that's a good exercise yeah
so um
first of all thanks for the talk it was
very interesting but
you
we were mentioning a lot of speed how
does it compare with the faster bear on
the Block in this case uh polars
um
that's a good question mark do you have
benchmarks against spoilers uh
yeah
okay so um I'll just repeat Mark's
answer at same ballpark as spoilers uh
migrations are comparable but I think
the main difference there is that we do
support a wider range of operators so
for example if you try to run tpch
classical analytical Benchmark
controllers and won't be able to run all
the queries because I think followers
don't support sub queries for example
uh also like out of memory execution
followers has some support to it if they
are uh streaming queries we fully
support it so it is performance but also
usability to a different range of cases
any more takers for the cube
I'm glad I didn't walk all the way back
down
um what I was interested in I think
sqlite was meant as a local development
database for for example building
applications well while drb could do it
for analytical purposes but when you
then go to production you often shift
the database Engine with something that
can scale even further is that also the
purpose for dugdb or should you run
dagdb also in production then
um uh in production is scale even
further so you mean like going to the
cloud Glasgow they were data warehouse
scenario or yeah exactly uh so the
current purpose of the DB right now is
to be something to that actually
exploits their full capacity on your
laptops
uh so it's not made to be a distributed
database system we do have a partner
company uh that's trying to do exactly
that but it's uh in the sense of okay
your data starts to grow you cannot
execute a queries on your uh computer
anymore so the name of the company is
model duck uh
before I forget to mention they called
themselves the mother duckers so very
nice people yeah but then uh it's like
okay if it doesn't support your laptop
you can actually seamless grow to Cloud
environment at some point but currently
uh it's really focused on getting the
max out of your
the desktop laptop single nodes
okay clear thank you
are there any other questions
come on this is your chance to make me
walk again not there in the back yeah
all right
so thanks for the talk a quick question
regarding the design when it comes to
like exceeding the memory available I
assume that by default you spill to disk
but is there a way to actually Force the
failure of the database and say uh okay
uh if you have like for example very
strong resource limitations uh do you
can you rely on stuff like c groups or
do you have some internal settings to
force the failure if you don't have
enough memory
to avoid spilling to disk basically
um I don't think we have a way of
forcing Federal because you don't have
enough memory I'll be there okay thanks
Mark uh but
okay you can set the memory limit but
does it this cause a fender that's in
the in the pragmas right yeah okay for
the progress
sorry yeah you can set the memory limit
and um basically you need to specify a
location on disk to spill too if you
don't specify that then it won't spill
be able to spill and then it will fail
okay
thanks but our queries are also uh you
can also cancel them if you wish so
it's also an option
so we have time for one more question
does anyone have one more one more
otherwise I will come up with one more
oh yeah thank you random person that I
don't know
so as you guys might know we actually
come from the far far away land of
Amsterdam
and we did had to bring for you guys all
of you here mugs and hats and mugs are
heavy so we brought them we don't want
to bring them back please if you don't
have a mug and a cap and a bar opener
yes best buyer Booth got some of our
merch we really brought it for you guys
so don't make us bring it back
[Applause]